bonjour Hervier Marseille bonjour vous
avez donc été reçu ce midi par la
première ministre Élisabeth barne pour
évoquer le projet de loi immigration et
la commission mixte paritaire de ce
lundi quel message vous a-t-elle passé
est-ce qu'elle a défini les lignes
rouges dans la négociation entre la
majorité présidentielle et la droite et
le centre du
Sénat d'abord premièrement le Sénat a
toujours été attentif à ce qu'il y ait
un texte ça a été le cas pour les
retraites ça a été le cas pour
l'immigration donc nous sommes désireux
qu'il y ait un texte au Sénat et nous
groupe PUC nous souhaitons aboutir donc
la première ministre a évoqué les points
qui pouvaent
faire difficultés lesquels oh le code de
la nationalité la donc le durcissement
de l'accès à la nationalité voilà et
médic d'État donc on peut aboutir à un
accord
mais les conditions ne sont pas encore
réunies pour qu'il y ait un accord parce
que ce sont des sujets qui sont
difficiles et il y a une double
condition c'est de trouver un accord
pour la commission mixte paritaire mais
également un accord susceptible d'être
validé par le Sénat et par l'Assemblée
nationale donc il faut satisfaire les
deux assemblées c'est un exercice
difficile donc est-ce qu'il y a un
accord global sur l'ensemble du texte ça
veut dire abandonner de part et d'autrre
un certain nombre de choses ou alors un
accord partiel sur une partie du texte
et justement donc ces lignes rouges
fixées par ellisabeth borne la
restriction de l'aide médicale d'État le
durcissement de l'accès à la nationalité
est-ce que vous demandez à vos collègues
sénateurs les républicains d'être souple
et de faire ses concessions d'abandonner
ses mesures non j'en ai pas le pouvoir
simplement on va dialoguer envoyer un
message on va dialoguer avec nos
collègues du groupe républicain comme on
le fait d'habitude dans dans le cadre de
la majorité
sénatorial chacun va évaluer j'allais
dire jusqu'où il est prêt à aller pour
trouver un accord et puis on reverra
certainement la la premierre la première
ministre mais on a l'impression que en
tout cas vos collègues de la majorité
les républi sont très dur ils veulent
absolument le texte du Sénat est-ce que
du côté des centristes où on souhaite
peut-être davantage un accord de cette
négociation et bien on appelle à faire
des concessions du côté du Sénat moi je
suis ravi d'abord de de constater que on
trouve beaucoup de vertu désormais au
texte du
Sénat c'était pas le cas au moment où il
a été voté il est jamais trop tard pour
pour bien
faire c'est le texte du Sénat
aujourd'hui qui prévaut il faut pouvoir
faire des
concession je pense qu'on on peut pas
faire non plus n'importe quoi parce que
c'est le fruit d'un compromis ici et
donc je ne sais pas jusqu'où on peut
aller pour satisfaire la majorité un
accord et l'Assemblée nationale je pense
que il y a un certain nbre de compromis
poss possiblebles mais pas sur des
choses essentielles maintenant nous
préférons un texte global qu' un texte
partiel c'est
évident je pense qu'on peut trouver
est-ce qu'il faut s'accrocher à l'aide
médicale d'État à cette restrié peut
faire l'objet la première ministre
l'avait déjà annoncé un accord à partir
d'un texte qui serait discuté au mois de
janvier donc euh on dit que c'est un
cavalier législatif on peut le sortir du
texte immigration et en faire un un
texte qui soit un texte différent mais
au tout début de l'année reste les
problèmes de code de la nationalité euh
qui sont importants les textes également
concernant les allocations euh on le
rappelle hein la droite sénatoriale
souhaite que les certaines prestations
sociales soient conditionnées à 50 de
résidences régulières aujourd'hui c'est
6 mois ça c'est c'est une rouge et un
point de blocage pour l'instant pour
l'instant ça fait l'objet de de
discussion donc nous allons en parler
entre nous moi j'espère qu'on trouve des
solutions parce que au fond au bout de
tout cela ce qui importe c'est de
trouver des réponses c'est ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens c'est pas
des palabres c'est pas des motions de
rejet de la politique aie ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des résultats et des
réponses à leurs attentes c'est ce qui n
nous efforçons de de faire maintenant
dernière question est-ce que le
calendrier très serré de cette
négociation souhaitée par Emmanuel
Macron c'est-à-dire une réunion lundi
pour un vote dans les chambres mardi
est-ce que ça peut faire échouer le
texte nous nous avions souhaité avec le
président du Sénat euh et et Bruno
retillot nous avions souhaité que nous
ayons du temps pour pouvoir préparer
tout ça discuter
négocier l'exécutif ne l'a pas voulu il
veut aller vite il veut en finir cette
précipitation peut être une source de
complication